matin en périphérie de dijon un barrage
filtrant vers 8 heures entre à huit
fontaines certains gilet jaune ont passé
la nuit ici
la police intervient pour libérer
davantage le trafic ce qui déplaît un
peu aux manifestants le mouvement qu'on
a fait depuis samedi donc on va
débloquer un peu plus donc elle les
rockets qui sont avec nous aujourd'hui
donc on va essayer de le claironner haut
si vous nous aidez plus tard dans la
matinée devant la raffinerie du midi à
dijon
des gilets jaunes bloquent l'entrée du
site au bout d'une petite heure
d'occupation les forces de l'ordre
interviennent dans le calme le mouvement
va continuer et c'est surtout qui va se
multiplier
on a beaucoup de gens qui nous
soutiennent là pour l'instant c'est un
dépôt c'est un dépôt après ça peut très
bien et une rocade s'il y aura de
multiples points
beaucoup en la halle pour le coup on en
cas absolument pas d'idées donc de
toutes façons vaut qu'ils préparent bien
joué au chat et à la souris avec nous le
groupe décide d'occuper alors un rond
point très fréquenté à l'est de dijon
grâce aux réseaux sociaux les gilet
jaune vont se relayer dans l'après-midi
sur facebook en fait on a les infos en
temps réel des gens interagissent
souvent et c'est comme ça qu'on suit en
fait le cours des choses et qu'on sait
où on se rejoint en fin d'après midi le
trafic s'intensifie
les ralentissements sont sensibles sur
la liaison nord un groupe filtre et
explique le mouvement aux automobilistes
là aussi l'organisation repose sur les
échanges de messages
on a donné les numéros de téléphone
depuis samedi et on essaie d'être en
contact avec les réseaux sociaux en plus
voilà ça aide pas mal
et puis après on se dit entre nous
maintient sa serais bien les la gale et
là on une partie des gilet jaune occupe
encore cette nuit certains points de
passage plus que jamais la mobilisation
est entretenue sur les réseaux sociaux